débardeur ponchos pull ou encore des
sacs on peut tout faire soi même et en
tricot une motivation pour kathleen
scientiste ban qui a ouvert en septembre
dernier sa propre boutique
j'aime beaucoup tricoter déjà de passer
après est un tout petit pardon à un
grand mère et je me suis remise à
tricoter vraiment quand je suis tombée
enceinte pour ses côtés pour mon bébé
comme beaucoup de jeunes mamans et donc
j'étais en licenciement économique à ce
moment là j'avais déjà l'idée de créer
une société enfin j'avais toujours envie
de travailler à mon compte et en fait je
me suis dit pourquoi pas ouvrir une
boutique de laine vendre des pelote
donner des conseils mais aussi animer
des ateliers le tricot ce n'est pas
seulement le gros pulls en laine divers
il ya aussi les fils d'été avec du coton
il n'y a pas de l'âne du coup on n'en
parle pas beaucoup on parle souvent de
la laine mais on ne fait pas mais on
peut aussi tricoter pour les paie donc
chaque composition est différente chaque
couleur est différente et chaque texture
aussi est différente matheson qui sont
bien tissé et puis d'autres ils sont un
peu plus fantaisie à l'image des tricots
café venu des états unis 4 lille senti
cette banque propose aussi des ateliers
où se mêlent apprentissage et
convivialité
vous avez la façon de monter il était
collé couture à plat que je ne
connaissais pas pour moi même d'un
ménage c'est une découverte il ya des
personnes qui ont commencé avant moi qui
s'y connaissent et je peux apprendre
beaucoup d'eux preuve que le tricot a
encore de beaux jours devant lui la
journée mondiale qui lui est consacrée
aura lieu le 11 juin 2016 à vos
aiguilles